how's it going everyone this is Daniel
from the chess website and Welcome to
our video on the domiano defense now the
domiano defense is an opening for black
albeit not a very good one after the
moves E4 E5 Knight F3 and this move Pawn
to F6 so the domiano defense was named
after Portuguese chess player and author
Pedro Damiano he lived from 1480 to
1544 and even though the openings named
after him he did deem it not a very good
opening he did suggest rightfully so
that moves Knight C6 and D6 are superior
to this move F6 the thing about F6 is it
has a lot of positional drawbacks you
prevent the knight from developing to
its favorite Square which is F6 and also
and possibly more importantly you weaken
this diagonal which is pointing right to
the king so as you can already maybe see
there are some tactical motives that
could arise after the move F6 is played
now white has a number of decent options
they can just play a move like Bishop C4
or even D4 is totally aable move however
the most challenging reply by white is
this Knight sacrifice with Knight takes
E5 so you go Knight takes E5 and the
idea is quite simple after Blacky
captures you go Queen H5 check and then
you begin a journey against the king
what I will note is that after this move
Knight takes E5 black doesn't have to
capture it but if they don't you're
simply down a pawn and have a bad
position due to this F6 move probably
the most prominent player to actually
try the Damiano defense for whatever
reason was uh choran who was a world
champion contender in the uh 1800s in a
game that he played he played the move
Queen E7 which attacks the Knight and
tries to sort of regain this Pawn but
after move Knight F3 it might seem like
you can regain this Pawn but once you
play Bishop E2 and start developing and
harassing the queen it's just not a good
position for black so black tried to
move D5 but then after D3 takes takes he
did end up taking the pawn and soon
enough white just got developed and
castled then started harassing the queen
and then played this nice move Knight E5
which looks like it's sacrificing the
Knight but if that it's a very temporary
one because of this move Bishop H5
exploiting the Queen's placement and
white just ended up winning a queen on
move 11 and black ended up sorry white
ended up messing it up so the game
ultimately ended in a draw but even at
the top level at the top level the
domiano defense has never tried and if
it is they're more likely to play a move
like Queen E7 I think even like I want
to say Knight e7's like one of the main
lines and then like D5 or something like
that but again it's just a bad position
for black like there's no upside to
trying it now here's the actual critical
part that you'll want to know if you're
going to be facing the domano defense if
they take in this position you go Queen
H5 check so that's the whole reason why
you sacrifice with Knight E5 in the
first place which is to go Queen H5 so
you deliver check black has two ways to
get out of check if black plays G6 then
you can simply just take on E5 and you
Fork the king and the Rook so you've
already sort of gotten what you want
material-wise black can play Queen E7
and then take on e4 but You' just go
King D1 you can also go Bishop E2 but
then after Queen G2 they're attacking
The Rook it might get a little bit weird
so here it doesn't really matter but I
would go King D1 if you remembered and I
mean you're attacking the Knight but not
only that there are like several ways
for you to attack the queen
now after Queen H5 black will often
times just not want to like just give up
The Rook for free maybe they realize
they mess up and then they'll just be
like okay I'm going to play King E7 and
make you prove that your sacrifice is
good so after King E7 there's one
obvious move here which is just to take
the pawn so we go Queen takes E5 check
black only has one legal move which is
King F7 after King F7 should be pretty
obvious from here now the king is on
this open diagonal and which piece can
go to that diagonal the bishop so you
play Bishop to C4 check now technically
black can survive longer or more
effectively I guess if they just play
this move D5 and allow you to take but
we'll show the variation first if they
go King G6 cuz again you just see that
the queen is covering all these squares
so the king cannot just just hide the
King has to go out and then in this
position you go Queen F5 check so once
again you're sort of just making this
box that the king can't get out of then
after King H6 you just crush them with
this move d4 or you could play D3 it
should be the same result you open up
the bishop to their King and it would
pretty much be Checkmate the only way
for black to not be literally in
Checkmate well they can play Queen G5
you obviously just take it no worries in
this position black could play G five
but then after this H4 move you're just
in complete control of the game like
there's just about nothing that black
can do to survive this attack um if they
let you take then it's just game over
then King G7 you would go Queen F7
Checkmate so we'll just say if like
something random played then your threat
is to take so it's a double check they
only have one square which is King G7
and then you get checkmate so you can
see the pawn covers some key squares the
queen is protected by the bishop and it
all works out in your
favor if they try to escape in the first
place with King
G7 then you can just go Queen F7 check
you're protected by the bishop King
hides on H6 and then you can play Pawn
takes G5 Checkmate it's opened up by The
Rook Pawn's protected and the queen is
covering a lot of key squares as well so
black could prolong it by playing this
move after Bishop C4 check they could
play D5 and the idea is that after
Bishop takes D5 now they can play King
G6 and you no longer have Queen F5 check
because of the bishop however it's still
pretty bad I believe the top move here
is H4 and then your plan to just go like
H5 and drive the king just into
Checkmate and then if they play H6 you
can actually play this move Bishop takes
B7 check so the idea is that you would
get Queen to F5 Checkmate again you
don't have to remember all that but
that's just an option that you can try
so yeah that's the domano defense um the
domiano defense occurs after black plays
this move F6 which I think almost every
decent chess player would consider a
mistake so if you're playing chess and
you see these moves E4 E5 you play the
Knight and then they play as move F6
then you should just know instantly to
just sacrifice on E five and then go
check and everything works out for you
so that is the domiano defense thank you
so much for watching this video and I'll
see you for the next one take care